the can is full of compressed gas under
pressure it's liquid hit the nozzle and
it sprays out as a gas but what about
its potential for combustion catastrophe
to find out first a flammability test
playing the role of our ignition source
will be this year lighter which will be
lit from a safe distance by our handy
dandy incinerator 8000 because you know
try not to lose Nyberg hey it's time for
us to have a talk I know I don't need to
tell you not to try this at home but
this story involves a paper shredder and
canned air two things you find in a lot
of households so let me add one more bit
of discouragement to this mix and that
is the propellant of this camp it's
great for our ozone it doesn't deplete
it but when you set that propellant on
fire it creates a couple of really
poisonous compounds so please don't try
this at home with everyone safely in
position it's time for ignition but
there's no liftoff yep the liquid
propellant is vaporizing into gas but
team shredder has an idea to alter the
mix maybe if we flip it upside down then
it will get a better result hey do it
okay let's go try that it's time to flip
this can upside down Oh
the theory is that gravity will push
more liquid down through the nozzle
adding more fuel to the fire
okay this is canned air of fun ability
test upside down cans in three two
[Music]
that is so cool really cool that was
awesome
so can air is flammable upside down Wow
nice
so by intentionally misusing their bust
off the team has the desired outcome